voilà une vie normale gal elmaleh de
jésus était jusqu à temps c'est juste au
24 juin
oui 24 juin vous reprenez la rentrée
puisque là ce soir
tout le monde sait sur quoi c'est vous
vous en moins 15 septembre ji nahd aux
folies bergère le 26 septembre 17 août
au bobino et vous non moi c'est jusqu'au
24 juin et après non et après oui en
tournée à apprendre tournée dans toute
la france très bien alors il ya ça donc
à ce spectacle et puis à un film aussi
on fait comme on a dit de philippe
béranger avec atmen kelif gilbert melki
sophie gilman marche bien ce film a en
ce moment
ouais c'est bien commencé dans l'ennui
de cédric kahn et on la voit partout
maintenant elle est dans harry le film
qui a beaucoup impressionné car semaine
dernière et ils vont le bolloc'h
c'est quoi l'histoire c'est quatre
chômeurs qui décide de braquer une
banque
parce qu'ils s'ennuient quoi pas parce
que c'est des vrais braqueurs parce
qu'il s'ennuie donc ils vont braquer une
banque
et ils font ça très mal c'est une
comédie et
et donc voilà je raconte pas toute
l'histoire mais en gros ça commence
comme un polar c'est sa mine comme les
pieds nickelés on peut dire ça il sort
le 24 mai